Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Podcast UFO. Wir haben beide Sonnenhals, wir haben keinen Bock mehr, es ist alles funktioniert nicht so richtig, die Technik und so. Ey, wir wurden von amerikanischen Choreografen aus unserem Aufnahmeraum geschmissen, sind jetzt hier nebenan in der Maske. Wir sind reingelaufen, sie haben gesagt, und geht wieder raus, in fünf, sechs, sieben, acht und raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus. Technische Probleme konstant, es kann jederzeit abbrechen, wir haben wirklich, wir nagen auf dem Hungertuch momentan an technischer Form. Es ist schrecklich. Wir entwickeln uns auch zurück. Du bist so müde, ich habe Kopfschmerzen, ich habe jetzt gerade so Vitamin-C-Dings eingeworfen, weil ich gehört, ob Vitamin-C gut ist. Warum ist Vitamin-C gut und warum heißt es dann Vitamin-C, wenn es das beste Vitamin ist? Ich weiß es auch. Nenn es doch Vitamin-1. Nennt das in der Reihenfolge, wie man es einnehmen sollte. Aber du bist halt auch so ein klassischer Symptombekämpfer. Du hast ein Symptom und bekämpfst es dann und denkst, ah, jetzt nehme ich Vitamin C zu mir und dann geht es sogar weg. Weil ich weiß, die Ursachen brauche ich gar nicht zu bekämpfen, weil da gibt es nichts zu bekämpfen. Dann muss ich ja aktiv mein Leben besser machen oder verändern. Langfristig. Nimm das jetzt aber jetzt jeden Tag, dann geht es dir besser. Dabei bin ich so erholt, Leute. Ich bin so erholt.
Ich war eine Woche nicht da, ihr habt es vielleicht gemerkt, es gab keine Folge Podcast, Uwe.
Ich war auf den Malediven.
Es ist kein Scheiß, ich war wirklich, es klingt immer wie ein Witz, man erzählt das Leuten und sagen, wo warst du wirklich, so Sylt oder so, nein, zwei Wochen auf den Malediven.
Es ist so, deine Figur verschwimmt völlig momentan.
Es war wunderbar.
Einerseits bespielst du so ein bisschen diesen, ah, ich bin der Student, der irgendwie einmal in der Woche bei Lieferando bestellt und haha-Modus. Andererseits fährst du auf die Malediven eine Woche und schwimmst mit Mantarochen. Wer bist du denn? Stefan, wer bist du? Weißt du, ich bin, ich bin, ich schwimme zwischen allen Welten so ein bisschen. Wie so ein Keyboard. Ich spiele alle Instrumente so ein bisschen an. Ja, aber sie klingen alle scheisser als Midi. Ich bin auch fast gestorben beim Schnorcheln, aber weißt du, das ist halt auch ein bisschen gefährlicher Lifestyle. Aber es war echt schön. Ey, das ist so spannend, das Land, weil es, tatsächlich habe ich ein paar Funfacts vorbereitet über die Malediven. Der erste Funfact wäre... Das ist die Liste? Das ist die Liste im Funfact. Ich habe hier so eine Karteikartenkiste, siehst du?
So, Funfact, die Malediven sind im Schnitt nur einen Meter hoch, der höchste Punkt der Malediven ist zwei Meter vierzig hoch.
Das ist der Sprungturm, oder was? Das ist der Sprungturm vom Pool, tatsächlich, und die haben ein Riesenproblem, weil in ein paar Jahren ist das Land weg, einfach weil der Meeresspiegel, weisst du ja, steigt jedes Jahr ein bisschen. Und in ein paar Jahren ist die Maldiven weg. Und der letzte Präsident hat irgendwie so eine Petition gestartet, dass sie doch bitte einfach den Staatshaushalt grösstenteils da rein investieren in einen Topf, um Geld zu sammeln, um irgendwann mal Land zu kaufen. Zur Wahl stand Land in Russland, Teile von Russland, Teile von Australien, Teile von Sri Lanka. Und dann haben die jetzt aber nach einem Jahr keinen Scheiss abgebrochen, weil die gemerkt haben, das ist zu teuer. Wir kriegen niemals so viel Geld. Wenn die einfach das ganze Land umziehen, oder was? Ja, wir hätten das ganze Land, alle Leute von Maldiv hätten, werden umgezogen nach Sri Lanka. Und ich stelle mir vor, Russland sind ja auch einfach teilweise arschkalte, das sind einfach so Leute, die immer 30 Grad gewohnt sind, die ziehen dann einfach alle gemeinsam um, schön, Sibirien. Kann man nicht von dem ganzen Topf einfach dem ganzen Land Gummistiefel kaufen und dann hat sich das Problem? Ich dachte mir auch so, einfach immer ein bisschen Sand drauf holen, so große, weiß ich nicht, alles ein bisschen höher machen, so Betonien einmal. Tatsächlich bauen die manchmal Inseln nach, weil die hier die Schaufeln dann manchmal Inseln. Also die können ja, das ist halt alles, sind so Atolls, die teilweise auch unter dem Wasser liegen. Wenn man einfach ein bisschen Sand draufschaut, da kannst du mit der Hand auch machen, hast du so eine kleine Insel erstellt. Was ist ein Atoll? Du bist das gewohnt, in diesem Karibik-Slaying jetzt zu reden. Nach einer Woche benutzt man so Wörter, als wären sie einfach da. Ja, ja. Ich glaube, das sind einfach Korallenriffe, so unter dem Wasser, also so kraterförmige, schwierig zu sagen. Das deutsche Wort ist schwierig. Kleiner Fun-Fact, als wir für einen Namen für gute Arbeit Originals gebrainstormt haben, sind wir durch Tausende von verschiedenen Namen gegangen. Und ein Begriff, der immer wieder aufgetaucht ist, war Atoll. Ich fand Atoll so ein tolles Wort. Das war irgendwie so Fun-Atoll oder Space oder irgendwie verschiedene Kombinationen. Dann hatten wir dann so ein grosses Whiteboard mit hundert Begriffen und nochmal hundert Begriffen auf dem anderen Whiteboard und dann hatten wir, okay, das sind zehntausend. Genau, wir dachten einfach, nach Klang gehen wir mal und haben uns die coolsten, die schönsten Wörter genommen. Pinguin, Atoll, Atoll, Atoll, Jack, Jack, Atoll, das war ein weirdes Hin und Her raten, wo man nicht mehr genau wusste, reden wir gerade noch miteinander, wir haben uns auch begrüsst mit Hallo, Fidji Atoll. Aber ich habe mich auch ein bisschen in das Wort Atoll verliebt. Es ist einfach so ein... Das ist toll. Aber niemand weiß genau, was es ist. Was ist eine Lagune? Erklär mir mal bitte den Unterschied zwischen der Lagune und der Bucht. Oh jo, ich glaube Bucht ist grösser, ich glaube Lagune ist auch schöner.
Ich glaube Lagune hat weniger Müll rumliegen zum Beispiel. Lagune ist ein bisschen hat mehr sowas. Lagune ist sogar Unterwasser. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen der Lagune und dem Riff? Das Riff. Klassisch das Riff, Korallenriff. Was ist ein Golf? Ein Golf ist eine grosse Lagune. Sehr gut. Ich glaube, Riff ist Teil eines, einer Lagune, Lagune ist Teil einer Bucht, Bucht ist Teil eines Golfs. Ein Golf kann mehrere Lagunen haben und mehrere Golf, mehrere Riffe und mehrere Lagunen. Es ist nicht so ganz durchsichtig, glaube ich. Das sind diese Marineausdrücke, die ich auch nicht genau weiß.
Aber ich finde es grossartig, dass du dieses arme Land ausbeutest und einfach in ihrer Not, in der sie Geld sammeln, weil sie gerade auf einem sinkenden Schiff, einer sinkenden Insel leben, kommen die ganzen scheissen Touristen vorbei und sagen, ja, ich will dir noch meinen Pina Colada am Strand, während alle Kinder gerade versuchen wegzulaufen und durchs Meer zu schwimmen, um wegzukommen. Vor allem, wenn mir so ein Mitarbeiter doof kam von den Maledivern, da habe ich einfach so ein bisschen Sand genommen und ins Wasser geschmissen.
So einfach genommen und dann so, das mag ich jetzt so lange ein bisschen, wenn man ein fucking Pina Colada bringt. Okay, du Scheißidiot. Bitte nicht, bitte nicht, meine Kinder. Ich bring eure Insel um. Einfach. Das war echt interessant. Ich hab da mit einem Malediver gesprochen, der mir dann meine Handtücher gebracht hat bei den neuen. Und da hat's geregnet, da ist ein Monsoon-Schauer runtergekommenkommen und das müsst ihr euch vorstellen, es ist von einem Moment auf den anderen macht es und es kommt einfach literweise Regen runter, literweise Regen, den ganzen Tag ist es 30 Grad warm, ist auch keine Wolke am Himmel oder so, ein Wochenende von jetzt auf gleich und regnet es einfach, wenn es einfach Wasser was runterkommt, das Meer fällt vom Himmel und in kam halt so ein, mit seinem Wagen so ein Maladiefer vorbei, der meine Minibar auffüllen wollte oder keine Ahnung was. Und der hat gefragt, ist der Rain in Germany too? Und ich habe gesagt, ja, aber das ist wesentlich anders. Ah, ist es dissimilar oder ist es different? Und dann habe ich ein bisschen mit dem gesprochen. Und er fand das so faszinierend, dass Regen nicht immer so ist, sondern Regen auch teilweise einfach tröpfelt. Und ich dachte, es ist auch so kalt, dass du nicht mehr draußen sein kannst und so. Er ist gar nicht verstanden. Und dann fiel mir so ein, ja, die hängen halt ihr Leben lang in diesem Paradies rum. Die kennen halt nichts anderes als das, die kennen halt nichts anderes als dieses blaue, lächerlich schöne Wasser, diese lächerlichen schönen Strände mit Palmen und so. Ich glaube, die kriegen, die sind so weit weg für die eine andere, das ist eine andere Welt. Ja, auch wenn du schlecht drauf bist, verstehen die gar nicht. Wenn du deinen Mundwinkel nach unten bewegst, kennen die gar nicht, weil die den ganzen Tag in der Sonne liegen. Schuhe gibt es auch nicht. Fun Fact, Monsunregen sind in der Nacht auf den Malediven nicht selten. Malediver hast du gerade gesagt? So nennt man die Menschen, die auf Maledivien liegen. Ja, ich dachte auch, haben die dann irgendwie ein spezielles Wort. Maledivuinen, Malediver ist glaube ich einfach das richtige Wort. Aber sind die, also das sind ganz viele kleine Inseln oder was? Ganz viele kleine Inseln, 90 Prozent des Landes sind Wasser. 99 Prozent der Landesfläche sind Wasser. Hauptstadt, one fact, ist Male. Das ist eine Insel, die ist ähnlich groß wie alle anderen, wohnen über 160.000 Menschen drauf. Heißt, es ist genau so eine kleine Insel. Hochhäuser. Es sind nur Hochhäuser nebeneinander. Es sind ganz viele Hochhäuser nebeneinander und eine Landebahn. Aber der Flughafen hat eine Eiseneinsel. Und das ist Male. Male ist die Hauptstadt, ist die grösste Insel. Aber kann man sich da nicht was ausdenken, dass man das mit dem Meeresspiegel hinkriegt, irgendwie den Grand Canyon fluten oder irgendwie? Ich meine, da muss man doch, da muss es doch Lösungen geben. Ja. Ich meine, du kannst, vielleicht bist du der letzte Mensch, der jemals auf den Malediven war und in hundert Jahren, weiss man nicht mehr, was das ist, einfach untergegangen. Ja, genau so wird es sein. Es ist das flachste Land der Welt und es wird untergehen. Und man lässt dann einfach die ganzen Urlaubsressorts einfach untergehen oder nimmt man die dann mit? Und dann, zwischenzeitlich hatte ich einfach Angst vor Tsunamis. Da sass ich abends dann so vor meinem Beach-Bungalow, wo die Palmen dann mir entgegengeweht haben und eine leichte Brise durch über den weht und die kleinen Krebse langsam die Nacht einläuten, da fiel ich mir ein, wow, da war ja 2004 ein sehr krasse Tsunami, wow, da habe ich mir ein paar YouTube-Videos angeguckt. Sehr gut. Und tatsächlich sind auf den Maldiven auch mehr als tausend Menschen gestorben, war gar nicht so weit weg. What? Mehr als tausend? Mehr als tausend Menschen, 82, ähm, 82? 82? Nee, mehr als tausend waren verletzt, 82 sind gestorben. Und da ist dann einfach, sorry, sorry, setzt euch wieder hin, Leute, die Wogen schlagen hoch. Zieht das Spendenkonto wieder zurück. Oh, die Wogen schlagen hoch im Tsunami-Bit, holy fucking shit! Ey, du bist richtig drin, Alter, mach weiter, mach weiter. Und dann sind da damals die Wellen gekommen, und die konnten sich vorbereiten, weil die wussten ja schon, was passiert. Die wussten ja schon, oh shit, da ist gerade was los. Und dann konnten sie sich noch ein bisschen retten und so weiter. Und dann seitdem habe ich mich, in meinem Zimmer war eine Rettungsweste. Ich habe mir so, hm. Und dann hat uns die Reiseleiterin von TUI, TUI ist übrigens die beste Reisegesellschaft, die hat mir dann gesagt, ja, damit sich die Gäste hier wohl erfüllen, hat man den Tsunami-Westen reingelegt, jedem wird aber nichts bringen, im Ernstfall. Und ich so, das, was du gerade sagst, mach das ein bisschen zunichte. Ich meine, ich sollte mich besser fühlen, vielen Dank auch. Aber du fühlst dich klüger, du fühlst dich klüger als die dummen Touristen, die denken, die würde was bringen. Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht sinnvoll, den Gästen zu sagen, wird nichts bringen, aber du fühl dich jetzt bitte besser. Ja, willst du dich sicher fühlen oder klug fühlen? Und dann hinkt da auch halt neben der Zunami-Wessel war eine Taschenlampe für Emergencies. Und dann habe ich gesehen, kann man nachts, sind manche Tiere halt nachtaktiv. Die Tierwelt ist atemberaubend da. Du bist halt, also du bist auf, ganz kurz, du kommst da an in Male, in dieser großen Stadt, auch nicht so groß, aber halt sehr viele Menschen, fliegst da mit einem Wasserflugzeug zu deiner Insel. Dein Hotel ist eine Insel, eine komplette Insel. Meine war nicht so richtig groß, war ungefähr sagen wir mal in eine Richtung so ein Kilometer, die andere so 500 Meter und da gehst du dann einfach rum und dann kannst du nachts, dann hast du überall Riffe und Korallen und Lagunen, golfartige Regionen und dann hast du halt überall Stachelrochen und normale Blaupunktrochen und Haie und das ist echt extrem viel Dinge kannst du da sehen, die du gar nicht für möglich hältst, die existieren, Flughunde, überall so Batman-Geschöpfe und dann nachts bin ich dann habe ich mir die Taschenlampe genommen, bin, habe Nachtspaziergang gemacht um die Insel herum und du, das ist so schön, das ist wirklich, da dachte ich mir, ja, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich Sonnenmensch.
So richtig schön, Sonnenuntergang oder dann so richtig nachts?
Ja, nachts, nee, richtig nachts, stockfinster, es war nachts. Manchmal bin ich auch noch um ein und nachts aufgestanden, weil da auch Babyschildkröten geschlüpft sind, äh, geschlüpft sind nachts. Und dann konntest du sehen, wie die schlüpfen und ins Wasser laufen.
Die hast du wieder ins Land weggeworfen.
Hab ich wieder reingeworfen.
Life is tough, motherfucker! Lernst lieber jetzt! Ciao! Aber haben die eigentlich die kleinen Baby-Schildkröten, haben die schon Panzer? Ich hab leider Super Mario getroffen und er ist dann geplatzt. Ja, dem schon Panzer. Haben die schon Panzer oder ist das dann auch so... Weil du hast ja... Wir haben ja letztens erklärt, dass Kinder ein Loch im Kopf haben, wenn sie geboren werden und dass der Kopf noch so Matsch ist. La Fontanelle. Ist das da nicht auch so irgendwie bei den Schildkröten, dass sie noch so... Weil ich habe mal so ein Bild gesehen... Im weichen Panzer, damit er noch wachsen kann. Ich habe mal so ein Bild gesehen von einer Schildkröte, die in so einem Sixpack-Plastikding gefangen war. Und da war der Panzer auch komplett so darum geformt. Also die muss als Babyschildkröte da festgesteckt sein, dumm. Und dann ist sie weitergewachsen und hat sich das alles drumherum gewachsen. Das heißt, man kann die sich, also theoretisch kannst du so eine Flugzeugschildkröte bauen, wenn du halt so, sagen wir mal, einen 3D-Drucker so eine Form baust, für so ein Flugzeug. Und dann setzt du die halt, als Baby setzt du halt diesen Hut auf und dann wächst es halt so Flugzeugen. Du meinst wie so eine Tragfläche und dann musst du die nur schnell laufen. Genau, und wenn die sehr schnell schwimmt, dann fliegt sie so hoch und dann hast du eine fliegende Schildkröte und sagst Tschau und sie winkt noch und fliegt in den Sonnenunternehmen. Oder so, der Panzer sieht so aus, als wäre es falsch rum. Und dann denkt die sich immer, what, was ist mit allen anderen los, warum fliegen die falsch rum durch die Luft, durch die Wasser? Tatsächlich habe ich ein bisschen Rochen lieben gelernt, weil ich dachte mir erst so, ich bin ins Wasser gegangen und ich bin halt ein typisches Ostseekind. Ich bin in meiner Kindheit und so oft in der Ostsee gewesen, das war so mein Meer, da bin ich immer reingegangen, da waren mal Quallen, da waren mal kleine Fische, Flundern, seltsame Tiere. Und jetzt plötzlich bin ich ins Wasser gegangen und dann wandern ein Hai sofort, einfach, und da waren Rochen einfach. Moment, also ein richtig grosser Hai, oder? Ja, richtig, also wirklich zwei Meter gross, teilweise auch drei Meter grosse Haie wandern, da Riffhaie, die tun nicht so viel und die sind auch sehr scheu und die merken auch, dass du da bist, eher als du die bemerkst und die fliehen dann schon und so. Aber auch richtig heftige Rochen, habe ich mal geguckt und Stachelrochen bringen ja auch einfach Menschen um. Also Stachelrochen sind ja saugefährlich, die können einfach Steve Irwin, der berühmte Crocodile Hunter, wurde ja von einem Stachelrochen einfach umgebracht. Damit geben die heute noch an die Biester. Ja, die haben auch hinten so ein We Kill Steve Irvin-Tattoos hinten drauf. Und die schwimmen da einfach rum, als wäre es einfach normal. Und alle Leute gehen dann da raus. Als würden sie da hingehören, die Scheißfieder. Und ich denke mir immer so, du hast halt, wenn du halt, stell dir mal vor, so eine Kamera, bist dann immer da dieven, und du hast immer rechts die badenden Gäste, und du hast die feiernden Gäste, die ein Pinacolada in haben und so, wuh, despachito singen und dann links tödliches Tier, tödliches Tier, tödliches Tier, rechts, wuhu, yeah, Malediven, yo. Und du hast einfach den Tod, das Schwimmen. Ich glaube, genau so ist Jaws entstanden, genau so ist der Weisserei entstanden, aus der Beobachtung so, hey, da sind Bikini-Girls und da ist das fucking gefährlichste Wesen der Erde. Das war faszinierend und die waren, die sind einfach tödlich. Und dann bist du ja auf den Malediven auch, um da zu schnorcheln. So, dann habe ich auch ein bisschen das Schnorcheln von mir gedacht. Und das ist natürlich, dachte ich, sehr einfach, du musst einfach die Maske aufsetzen und hast dann diesen Strohhalm nach oben und dann ziehst du einfach eine Luft, einfach durch diesen Strohhalm und dann schön ist da ein bisschen rum. Und dann habe ich so eine Einführung mitgemacht und ich dachte mir ja so, die wollen ja, die machen eine Erwerbung damit, dass Schnorchel bei denen so schön ist und so gut geht und so weiter. Dann fügen die aber komisch an, dieser Kurs, nämlich die haben zuerst gesagt, ja, bitte nur in folgenden Bereichen schwimmen, weil da oben da zum Beispiel nicht, weil da starke Strömung und da unten an der Insel auch. Und bitte nicht so weit rausschwimmen, hinter den Bolzen starke Strömung, da sind neulich zwei Menschen weggetrieben, die waren tot. Und ich so, okay, das war der erste Satz, den du gesprochen hast, das ist eine harte Ansage, dass jemand gestorben ist. Ja, in diesem Jahr sind bereits mehrere Menschen gestorben. Manche auch einfach im Wasser, da wissen wir so nicht warum, wahrscheinlich Herzinfarkt. Alles klar, okay. Wir wissen nicht warum. Es geht spannend weiter. Okay, und dann hat sie irgendwann so Schilder in der Hand gehabt, ich hatte mir, wofür sind diese fucking Schilder, da waren Bilder von Fischen drauf. Ihr habt Angst vor diesem Fisch, weil der wird euch umbringen, wenn ihr den berührt. Dann das sind Stachelrochen, die bitte nicht provozieren und nicht drauftreten, sonst bringen die euch um, wenn die drauftreten. Hier hast du Haie, die tun nichts, es ist aber schon mal vorgekommen, dass jemand angeknabbert wurde, aber alles nicht so schlimm. Das hier ist ein Drückerfisch, Drückerfisch, der sah lustig aus, der hatte so große Lippen, ist so klein und den bitte ganz vorsichtig sein, weil wenn der manchmal Nester hat, dann will er seine Jungen halt beschützen und wenn, dann kriegt er den Warnsignal, indem er dann seine Flosse hochstellt und wenn du das immer noch ignorierst, dann attackiert er dich. Dann nimmt er halt immer Anlauf und schubst dich einfach. Der fliegt halt mit seinen dicken Lippen, geht dann in dich rein. Küsst dich. Und küsst dich also ganz unangenehm doll und prügel dich so ein bisschen aus dem Wasser. Dann haben Leute einfach sehr viele blaue Flecken gehabt. Ich dachte mir, wo kommen die denn? Ja, von diesem Drückerfisch. Wie schnell, was? Wie schnell kann er denn schwimmen? Sehr schnell schwimmen, er ist ja im Wasser zuhause. Und dann drückt er dich einfach aus dem Wasser und dann
musst du wirklich
auf eine andere, zu einer anderen Küste gehen,
weil der halt dann, der merkt dich halt dein Gesicht
und der patrouilliert dann, dass du nicht mehr
reinkommst. Und da denke ich mir,
das ist schon hart.
Der würde auch einfach so ein Hai antotzen oder was, wenn der dazu
hat kommt. Ja, und die sind überall, die sind wirklich überall,
diese Drückerfische. Und ich habe auch Panik bekommen,
als ich manchmal diese Fische dann gesehen habe, wie die dann unten ihre Eier da rummachen. Das war ganz unangenehm. Und dann ging es weiter. Ja, und das ist ein Fisch, der sieht aus wie Stein, deswegen seht ihr den nicht. Bitte nicht drauftreten, sonst bringt ihr euch auch ein Steinfisch. Ja, Steinfische, die sind furchtbar. An die kann ich mich auch noch erinnern. Die waren für mich damals der Grund, warum ich aufgeregt habe zu tauchen. Ich habe auch da mal Tauchkurs gemacht. Und wo gab es die dann? Da gab es so ABC-Tauchkurs bei uns im Schwimmbad und ab C wäre da mit Flasche tauchen gewesen. Und ich habe A und B gemacht, halt so Schnorcheltauchen, Luftanhalten, so Techniken und Bergen unter Wasser gedönst. Und dann meine Eltern haben gemerkt, hey, der interessiert sich für Tauchen, wir schenken ihm ein Buch, irgendwie die Wunderwelt unter Wasser, was der grösste Fehler ist, den man überhaupt nur machen kann. Saugiftig, super saugiftig, potthässig, unfassbar schmerzhaft, saugefährlich. Und vor allem am meisten Angst hatte ich vor der Muräne. Alter, Muränen dutzendfach gesehen. Ja, vor allem, das ist ja die schlimmste Vorstellung der Welt, die kommen ja aus der Koralle geschossen, beißen sich einfach fest. Und die sind wirklich steinhart und die halten dich einfach unter Wasser fest,
bis du erstickst.
Und da dachte ich mir, okay, dann, ich gehe nie wieder ins Wasser.
Ich bin am Strand zufällig in eine Moräne getreten.
Aber sie war noch kleiner, deswegen ist sie sofort weggeschwommen.
Aber das war wirklich saugefährlich.
Ich denke mir, nebenan war so eine White Party,
einen Abend schrecklich, wo dann sich alle weiss anziehen mussten.
Und dann haben die Leute die Wolken gefeiert und so.
Und links war einfach der Tod im Wasser. Einfach eine Riesenmoräne. War für mich einfach der Grund, ich habe sofort abgebrochen. Ich wollte dann auch nicht Flaschen tauchen, weil dann irgendwas ist dann einfach zu krass. Fand ich auch krass. Naja, und dann habe ich nach so einem kurzen Zeit trotzdem mal geschnorchert. Und es war schon schön. Ich habe auch so eine GoPro mitgenommen, wo ich unter Wasser das gefilmt habe. Habe auch Schildkröten gesehen, es war wirklich toll Du warst dann ganz alleine unterwegs, also nicht in so einer Gruppe? Nö, einfach alleine. Und hattest du da irgendwie eine Ortung oder irgendeinen Kompass oder so? Nee, ich bin auch nicht so weit rausgeschnorchelt. Ich hätte da wirklich Angst, dass ich mich einfach verfahren. Viele Leute sind, aber du siehst ja immer die Insel und du hast auch die Karten in meinem Kopf und so. Du hast die Karten im Kopf, wenn du dann Sturm kommst und so was. Die sind nicht so groß, die Inseln, und dann siehst du ungefähr, wo man schwimmen kann. Und dann war halt der Strand da und eine 500 Meter Entfernung war dann das Riff, das Hausriff. Und dann könntest du da inzwischen halt gut schwimmen und da hast du mal Haie gesehen und mal Schildkröten und so. Aber meine Gags kamen nicht so an. Also das ist eine ganz fremde Kultur. Ich habe auch bis heute nicht verstanden, was sie genau sprechen, diese Malediver. Und ich dachte mir so, ja, mach so ein paar Gags mit den Kellnern und so, nope, kommt gar nicht an. Und irgendwann dachte ich dann, okay, ich habe mich darüber nachgedacht, wie komme ich jetzt, wie kommen meine Gags an? Komm, du machst das doch professionell, da musst du doch irgendwas machen. Und dann habe ich irgendwann gedacht, was ist die leichteste Form von Gags, die jeder versteht, Slapstick. Da dachte ich mir, okay, der Kellner hat was eingeschüttet, wollte dann zu mir kommen und mein Glas war auf der anderen Seite. Dann ist er einmal um den Tisch gelaufen und dann habe ich das Glas in der Zeit aber ihm hingeschoben, wo er vorher stand. Dann ist er quasi einmal umsonst am Tisch gelaufen und hat dann gesehen, dass er das Glas umgestellt hat. Ich dachte, ha, kleiner Scherz so und dann ist er dann einfach ohne was zu sagen, oh, sorry. Dann ist er wieder um den Tisch gelaufen und hat es dann eingeschüttet, wie das grösste, grösste Wichser kam ich dann rüber. Das war extrem unangenehm. Und dann waren halt auch so ein deutsches Pärchen war irgendwie da und mit denen habe ich da so ein paar Gags gemacht. Die waren leider im Wasser mit Luftmatratzen vor mir und dann sind die halt in der Strömung, sind dann die Luftmatratzen so leicht weggeweht. Und dann habe ich mit dem, ich habe Gespräch mit die haben aber auch nicht irgendwie dann gepaddelt, dass sie sich wieder drehen zu mir, sondern das Pärchen ist einfach langsam weggeslidet und so langsam in die Ferne gedriftet und ich so, naja, und dann habe ich ihr gesagt, und dann habe ich einfach aufgehört zu sprechen, weil das Gespräch war dann irgendwie vorbei, einfach schätze ich. Der schlechteste Ort für Comedy ist auf dem Wasser, das ist mir aufgefallen. Das stimmt, aber es ist auch so ungezwungene Gespräche, so du kannst, wenn du keinen Bock mehr hast, dann driftest du einfach weg und dann bist du wieder weg. Du musst einfach das Paddeln aufhören, du musst nichts aktiv machen. Aber nervig ist, wenn sich jemand an deine Luftmatratze dranhängt, weil wirst du nicht mehr los. Dann wirst du nie los. Das weiß ich noch. Da gab es im Urlaub immer Kinder, die dann dran gehen. Oh, geh weg. Nervig. Die können dann auch nicht so gut schwimmen, Kinder, und dann müssen sie sich überall festhalten und wirklich nervig. Und du, schön Badehose oder was? Klar, Badehose. Aber so eine Knielange oder wie muss man sich dich vorstellen? Nee, Speedo. Klar hathart Speedo. Aber ohne hinten auch quasi, dass man den Hintern komplett zu sehen ist. Wir müssen so eine kleine Speedo quasi, die nur so über die Ritze geht quasi. Ganz unangenehm. Ich bin ein unangenehmer Gast. Und du bist schön braun geworden. Ich bin tatsächlich braun geworden, hab mir auch wieder den massivsten Sonnenbrand geholt und dann fing es plötzlich so an zu jucken, dass ich dann mehr oder weniger auch aus Neugierde mal in die Inselklinik gegangen bin. Weil die Inselklinik mit Mahatma Guru als Chefärztin. Ja, und musste der Chefarzt darum kämpfen, dass die Klinik nicht geschlossen wird, weil irgendwie die reichen Leute woanders sind oder so. Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Staffel du da warst, von daher kann ich jetzt den Plot nicht genau sagen. Die Titelmusik war toll, und dann bin ich da reingegangen, und dann ... Die sprechen dann alle so ein bisschen gebrochenes Englisch, und dann hab ich halt immer so ein bisschen geteatet, als ob ich die verstehe, und immer so freundlich, ja, yes, yes, yes, yes. Und dann hat er was gesagt, und ich so, well, yes. Stellt sich heraus, er hat gesagt, ja, wir haben heute fast eine Frau verloren. Ähm fast ertrunken und dann habe ich das, da habe ich halt gelacht und in seiner Reaktion habe ich gemerkt, ich habe in die falsche Richtung gecheatet. Und dann habe ich gesagt, oh, aber ich würde in einem Krankenhaus auch nie die Lachnummer fahren. Ich würde immer die, aha, aha. Aber er hat das nicht so gesagt, wie ich denke, so sagt man jetzt, dass eine Frau fast umgekommen ist. Weil er war noch sehr erleichtert, weil die gerade haben die wiederbelebt oder sowas. Und das ist wirklich, also der Tod war mir niemand zum Greifen nah auf diesem Paradies, muss man sagen. Und dann habe ich eine Sonnenallergie, die hat sich herausgestellt. Ich bin also gegen das einzige, was der Mensch neben Wasser braucht, massiv allergisch. Das ist so eine Lichtallergie irgendwie, dann hat sie mir so Zeug gegeben, das ging dann eigentlich nicht so gut. Einerseits bedenklich, andererseits auch bedenklich, dass du das erst im Alter von 23 Jahren herausfindest, dass du sonnenallergisch bist. Ich hab's immer gewusst, so ein bisschen, also es ist so ein Ding, du weißt, dass du's hast, du merkst, dass was mit dir nicht stimmt, du kannst es nicht in Worte fassen, und dann hat sie gesagt, du könntest eine Sonnenallergie haben. Ich so, ja, ja, ja, jetzt muss ich sagen. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich es nicht schon wusste. Kleines Service-Segment, was sind die Symptome einer Sonnenallergie? Wie findet man das raus? Starker Juckreiz. Bei Sonneneinstrahlung? Extreme Rötung, massive Sonnenbrände, Hautkrebs. Okay. Das ist so in etwa, also relativ unbedenklich. Und kann man da irgendwas dagegen machen oder kannst du da so Heuschnupfen mässig irgendwie dann Tabletten nehmen oder? Nee, so kannst du Antiallergikum und so nehmen und so. Aloe Vera. Aber hast du jetzt abgeschlossen mit der Sonne oder wie willst du jetzt? Ja, schon abgeschlossen. Ich habe auch immer in so einem Ganzkörperanzug. Danach bin ich mit Shirt schnorcheln gegangen. Das war ganz unergegeben. Das machen nämlich immer die fetten Leute, die immer mit Shirt schnorcheln gehen. Mit so Abi 2013 Shirts. Es ist halt die Frage, wenn du fett bist, ziehst du ein Shirt an und ziehst damit die Aufmerksamkeit auf sich, weil alle sofort aus großer Distanz schon sehen, du bist fett oder tust es nicht, dann gehst du in der Masse unter, aber bist halt fett. Ja. Weil man zieht sofort. Gehen fette Leute nicht immer in der Masse unter? Kleiner Spruch zum Nachdenken. Der Kalenderspruch für November 2014. Komisch, dass sich der so schlecht verkauft hat. Ja, mein Fat-Shaming-Kalender. Nee, aber es war schon wirklich toll. Also ich kann jedem raten, mal einmal die Maladiven auszuprobieren. Es ist wirklich einfach ein Paradies. Reiseempfehlung. Es ist die Reiseempfehlung, es ist wahnsinnig toll. Leute sind mit Mantas geschwommen, da muss man so ein Tagestour machen. Ich habe Delfine gesehen. Motorboot? Jetski? Ja, Motorboot war ich kurz. Und ich hatte eine Massage. Die war nämlich nicht dabei, die war in meinem All-Inclusive-Angebot drin. Eine 15-Minuten-Massage. Ich habe Back and Neck gemacht und es war ein bisschen anstrengend, es waren 15 Minuten lang Ankämpfen
gegen eine Erektion
und es war von daher, es sollte entspannt
sein, es war
sehr anstrengend, aber es
war auch sehr schön, weil das war
in so einer Holzhütte auf dem Wasser und du
konntest halt, du lagst dann auf diesem
die beste Art der Liege,
wo man auf dem Bauch liegt und dann hast du diese
Aussparung von dem Kopf und guckst auf den Boden und unten war halt ein Glas und du konntest ins Wasser gucken, wo immer Fische vorbeigeschwommen sind. Da musst du dich ein bisschen an deine Zahnarzt-Story denken, wo dann irgendwann so ein großer Haier vorbeikommt und man so, ah! Das war vor allem das Erste, was ich machen würde. Ich würde zu diesem Haus hinschwimmen und unter dem Haus durchtauchen und von unten in diese Löcher guckt und so, so, ah! Die Leute, die gerade tiefenentspannt sind.
Und dann schwimmt da plötzlich so ein Typ
vorbei, so ein fetter Typ.
Ich fand das schon so lustig, wie man da liegt.
Du liegst auf dem Bauch, aber du kannst gucken.
Diese Vorstellung, das ist genial,
mit dem Loch da drin. Du liegst auf dem Bauch
und dein Gesicht liegt auch
nach unten gerichtet. Das fand ich
so faszinierend schon. Gibt es nicht diese eine
Szene bei den Simpsons, wo die mit so einem Schiff fahren, das so ein Glasboden hat und dann gucken die so runter und dann sagen die so, ist das sicher? Und dann sehen sie durch das Fenster auf dem Meeresgrund ein Schiff liegen, das so ein riesiges Riss in dieser Glasscheibe hat. Und dann so, okay. Da finde ich das sehr lustig. Die Sims. Die sind gut. Aber da dachte ich mir auch, also die Musik war so beruhigend, so leicht asiatische Klänge und dann hat sie diese Glocke geläutet, also das war kein Alphysmus, sie hat wirklich den Gong geläutet und hat dann angefangen, mich mit dem Back and Neck zu massieren, hat wirklich tolle Stellen getroffen, wo ich dachte, wow, das ist genau richtig. Ja, wo würdest du sagen, ist dein Rücken G-Punkt, wo muss man mit dem Rücken damit... Es ist so ein bisschen neben der Wirbelsäule oben, neben den Schulterblättern, zwischen Wirbelsäule, Schulterblätter.
Das war da ganz tolle Worte, wo sie mich so angefasst hat. Hast du danach versucht, dich selbst zu massieren? Ja, ja, oft nicht geschafft. Ich habe mich manchmal auf die Hand gesetzt, damit sie taub wurde, damit die Durchblutung quasi mit meiner Hand eingeschlafen ist, und habe dann versucht, meinen Rücken zu berühren, damit es sich anfühlt wie eine fremde Hand. Verstehe. Der alte Masturbationstrick, aber hat nicht so gut funktioniert. Das war wirklich ganz toll. Und dann überall liegen, waren so Räucherstäbchen und Vasen, so große Vasen ohne Sinn. Einfach Vasen. Und liefen Räucherstäbchen, also Branden? Branden, Räucherstäbchen. Konntest du dir das aussuchen oder war das eher so Default? Nee, konnte ich nicht aussuchen. Das war Default, aber ganz toll. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, ich bin jetzt fertig, wir treffen uns in der Lobby. Ich hätte kurz Angst, weil, Kinder, bitte ich kurz Angst vor einem Happy End. Also weil, kündigen die das an vorher, sagen die dann, übrigens, das ist eine Massage, wo ich danach auch die Enden runterholen werde. Ist das, ich weiß nicht genau, ob man das nicht, aber bei Back and Neck war ich mir sehr sicher, dass das nicht passiert, so, aber ich hätte echt Angst bei so einer Ganzkörpermassage. Wie meinen Sie Ganzkörper? Vor allem, ich war nur mit Back and Neck Massage, und das erste, was sie gemacht hat, war meine Badehose runtergezogen. Die hat schon dann, dachte ich mir, der Rücken geht aber nicht so tief, dachte ich mir. Aber anscheinend in diesen Massagenwelten doch, ich weiß es nicht. War es so privat? Ich weiß nicht, ich will nichts, ich kenne in Köln gibt es so ein Massagesalon, wo immer so groß vorne draufsteht, so mit so einem grossen Warnschild, so hier, keine Erotikmassagen. Ja. Also da bin ich denkst, wie unangenehm. Auch so ein Augenrollsmiley. Ja, da bin ich so, Jesus, Leute, das ist ein ernstes Handwerk hier. Aber ja, andersrum will man es natürlich auch nicht ankündigen. Du willst natürlich auch nicht als Massages-Salon, der das ankündigt, sagen, hier Erotik-Massagen. Hier nur Erotik-Massagen. Nur das. Massage-Erotik. Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, je weniger ein Massage-Laden genauer in der Einkaufsstraße ist, also je mehr du mal links abbiegen musst. Je mehr du abbiegen musst, ist das wahrscheinlich ein Erotik wahrscheinlich eine Erotikmassage. War das die erste Massage in deines Lebens?
Ja, ja.
Ich wurde noch nie professionell massiert.
Es ist schon toll. Ich habe schon verstanden, warum das Leute machen. Also es macht schon, man fühlt sich danach auch echt besser.
Du bist einfach entspannter und ich hatte die ganze Zeit, da habe ich doch so einen Tee bekommen, so einen asiatischen, das war alles so eine Welt, wo ich dachte, ja, das ist die Welt, so buddhistischer Mönch ist schon das beste Leben, glaube ich. What? Die müssen nichts tun. Aber was hatte das mit Massage zu tun? Nee, ich denke mir, die haben diese Räucherstäbchenkultur, diese Vasen Räucherstäbchen zu tun. Ja, die zerschlagen aber auch Holzbrennen den ganzen Tag, ich glaube, das ist was anderes. Ja, aber auch, weil die halt die Energie so kanalisiert haben, weißt du? Und ich glaube, das ist auch so, die haben halt dieses ein bisschen dieses Spa-Leben. Ich glaube, das grösste, missverständlichste Geschichte, Stefan Tietze macht eine Massage und wird dann buddhistischer Mönch in Tibet. Ich dachte, das ist so wie eine Massage. Was muss ich den ganzen Tag meditieren? Naja, es ist halt dieses Meditieren Räucherstäbchen, dein Körper ist dein Tempelgedöns. Ja. Das habe ich jetzt schon so ein bisschen verbunden. Hey, probier es mal aus, mach mal so Schnuppertraining in Tibet. Kann man da mal reinschnuppern? Einmal mal reinschnuppern. Einmal mal reinschnuppern. So Probe-Probe-Mönch. Die haben bestimmt Bock auf Europäer, die vorbeikommen mit einer Glatze und dann irgendwie sich so Naruto-mäßig dann so Zeichen auf die Stirn machen. Vor allem, ich habe dann auch wahrscheinlich keinen, ich kenne diesen gelben Umhang nicht, ich ziehe mir einfach ein gelbe Shirt an und so einen Schal, so einen roten Schal, den ich drum wicke. So ein haftes Paar T-Shirt. Ich sehe so halb aus wie ein Mönch. Ja, ja. Und ich habe, ich traue mir auch nicht, eine Galaterglatze zu machen, aber auch meine Brille noch auf weiterhin und habe dann so eine Glatzenperücke irgendwie drüber, so eine Badekappe. Ja, vor allem diese Tibetan oder diese buddhistischen Mönche generell, das sind ja brutal krasse auch Martial-Arts-Leute, wenn du halt in die Richtung gehst.
Halt enorme Körperherrschung und dann Training und dann so und dann habe ich mal so ein Doku darüber gesehen, dass sie halt ultra krasse Sachen können, dann irgendwie so Metallstangen zerschlagen und sowas.
Und dann war die Frage so, ja was machen sie denn, wenn sie so fertig sind mit der Ausbildung? Und dann meinten die so, ja die meisten gehen ins Militär.
So war auch der so, holy shit, ey,
die haben die fucking krass, das ist das Militär der Welt.
Friedlichstes Leben hin zu töten.
Ja, du willst dich nicht mit denen anlegen,
weil die können irgendwie Nadeln durch Glasscheiben werfen und da hilft dann auch dein Panzer nichts mehr,
wenn die dann mit Nadeln kommen.
Und ich mir auch dachte, wow.
Ich denke, dass die halt so sehr kommunikative Berufe
plötzlich einnehmen, so Callcenter oder so,
weil die überkompensieren, dass sie uns nicht gesprochen haben.
Kann auch sein, die müssen nicht ausreden. Talkshow, Friseure. Hast du schon mal einen glatzköpfigen Friseur gesehen? Ja, ich habe schon mal einen tauben Friseur gesehen. Ja gut, aber das ist die Ironie, Alter, Gerd. Hast du schon mal einen Friseur ohne Kopf gesehen? Ich habe den blinden Friseur gesehen. Friseure. Friseure. Ich war so fasziniert nachts von dieser Nachtaktivität von Tieren, weil manche rochen und so waren halt nachtaktiv, deswegen habe ich die am Schrand halt gesehen. Und dachte mir, das ist schon genial von der Natur, dass plötzlich einfach eine Tierart nachtaktiv ist. Angenommen, ein Tier hatte jahrelang Probleme, wurden aneinander gefressen von Raubtieren, was machen wir, was machen wir, lass einfach nachts da sein. Die beste Idee der Welt, einfach nachtaktiv. Bis dann die Raubtiere irgendwann sagen, okay, jetzt sind wir auch nachtaktiv. Oder wieder zurück. Ja, ich stelle das in kleiner Kreisel einfach und es ist gerade random, welche Tiere gerade nachtaktiv sind, welche nicht. Du meinst, wenn man in 100 Jahren nochmal drauf guckt, ist es genau umgekehrt. Es ist genau andersrum, genau. Dann sind Rochen tagesaktiv und schlafen in der Nacht.
Aber sind Rochen denn immer am Boden so, scooten die immer so am Boden rum oder sind die auch so wie so ein Frisbee in der Luft dann?
Es gibt so und solche und solche.
Das war Herr Professor Tietze.
Es gibt Mantas, die sind teilweise drei Meter grosse Tiere.
Was?
Ganz tolle.
Nicht drei Meter.
Doch, du kannst auf den Schwimmen hin.
Du bist wesentlich drei Meter lang. Stefan, du weißt, wie groß du bist. Wird es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so Kopf durch. Und du bist sicher, dass die nicht einfach weit weg waren und du dich die Lichtbrechung im Wasser ein bisschen missverstanden hast? Vielleicht ist meine Schnorchelbrille auch so einen komischen, die war so weitwinklig, sah alles ein bisschen grösser aus. Sein eines Auge war riesig, das andere war so ganz klein. Ich habe halt acht Meter grosse Menschen gesehen. Tatsächlich war das Riesenmanta. Das ist ja so auch Loch Ness, glaube ich. Loch Ness ist einfach so eine Eidechse, die man da reingefallen ist, aber durch die Lichtbrechung im Wasser sieht das riesengroß aus. Und da denken sie sich, das ist Loch Ness. Ja, die sind riesig. Hier steht jetzt nicht ganz drei Meter, sondern zwei Meter, aber ihr wisst, you get the idea. Und die sind, die schweben dann wirklich auch oben durchs Wasser und die haben halt auch einen riesen Maul, was immer so aufgeht. Aber nur weil die Plankton halt essen, die wollen dann die ganzen Plankton sammeln die ein und dann machen die den Mund zu, wenn die auf dich zuschwimmen. Also die machen so ein paar Zentimeter vor dir als den Mund zu
und schwimmen dann unter dir her und so.
Und die Stachelrocher, die sind eher so am Boden, am Sliden.
Die haben aber lustige Augen,
weil die haben schon relativ grosse, menschenartige Augen.
Deren Körper ist ganz strange,
aber prinzipiell kann man sagen, sind die Unterwasservögel,
weil die halt, die machen auch so einen typischen Vogel-Fortbewegungs-Style.
Macht den Mund zu und rollt dann so die Augen,
so, ach Gott, jetzt muss ich aufhören zu essen.
Okay, ist okay.
Ihr seht doch, was hier los ist.
Vielen Dank. So einen typischen Vogel-Fortbewegungs-Style. Mach den Mund zu und roll dann so die Augen. Ach Gott, jetzt muss ich aufhören zu essen. Okay, ist okay. Ihr seht doch, was hier los ist. Leute, du kannst ja auch ausreichen. Arbeitswege freimachen, bitte. Ich finde es aber echt lächerlich, bei der Körpergröße eines Tieres den Stachel mitzuzählen. Wenn du einen Hund misst, dann misst du auch nicht den Schwanz mit. Natürlich. Nein, was soll das denn sein? Natürlich. Hä, dann ist ein Jaguar über zwei Meter gross. Ja, und Haie? Dann nimmst du auch die letzte Flosse mit. Natürlich. Nein, was soll das denn sein? Natürlich. Ja, dann ist ein Jaguar über zwei Meter gross. Ja, und Haie, dann nimmt es auch die letzte Flosse mit. Ja, aber eine Flosse ist das andererseits ein Schwanz. Na ja, du kannst als Körpergröße, das finde ich albern, du kannst als Körpergröße. Nee, aber ich meine, die haben schon eine Breite von drei Metern. Hm. Weiß ich nicht. Meinst du diese Wasserflugzeuge? Vielleicht hast du es verwechselt. Ist eines untergegangen?
Ist eines untergegangen. Aber hast du einen Oktopus gesehen? Ja. Nee. Aber, Entschuldigung. Holy shit, aber das, ähm, ein Wasserflugzeug zurück. Ja, nein, Husten. Klassische T-Zesafe. Wie komme ich aus der Situation wieder aus? Haben Sie ihn überhaupt begangen? Ja, nein. Alles klar, alles in Ordnung, alles in Ordnung. Tatsächlich, am Rückflug sind wir gestartet mit dem Wasserflugzeug. Und dann sind wir hingeflogen halt 45 Minuten vom Flughafen dahin. Ich dachte, zurückfingen wir auch 45 Minuten dann direkt zum Flughafen. Ich wusste nicht, dass wir noch andere Leute abholen im anderen Hotel. Dann sind wir nach zwei Minuten plötzlich wieder runtergegangen langsam, also nicht langsam, sondern zügig aufs Meer zu. Und da hat niemand gesagt, wofür landen wir übrigens nochmal? Und dann hat deren Bordcomputer das auch nicht gewusst anscheinend, die ganze Zeit emergency, emergency, attention, attention, retard, retard, zieht einmal ein fucking Flugzeug hoch. Und ich dachte mir, wir stürzen einfach ab. Aber ich hätte keine Angst. Ich hatte keine Angst. Ja, weil Wasser. Warum? Weil es ein Wasserflugzeug ist. Ja, ja. Das ist auch im Idealzustand. Auch wenn alles perfekt läuft, landet es im Wasser. Das ist so, fuck it einfach. Was soll uns passieren, dass wir plötzlich im Wasser sind? Okay, aber ob wir jetzt im 2-Meter-Tiefen-Wasser oder im 80-Meter-Tiefen-Wasser landen, ist doch scheißegal. Aber ich habe mir, das ist sogar cool. Ich dachte mir, wie cool cool, das kann sein Podcast erzählen, dass ich abgestürzt bin. Leider nicht, da haben andere Touristen abgeholt. Das ist eigentlich nicht doof. Warum sind nicht alle Flugzeuge, weil dann kannst du immer in Flüssen landen, wie dieser Sullivan. Ja, genau. Sully. Genau, die sind glaube ich von La Guardia gestartet, dann gab es einen Vogelschlag, da war so ein Vogelschwarm reingeflogen und dann mussten die im Hudson landen. Das ist angstentflüssend, aber du kannst rutschen. Und ein guter Film mit Tom Hanks, kann man sich anschauen. Guter Film? Ich fand ihn gut. Nicht gesehen. Ich fand ihn gut, ich fand ihn interessant. Weil der behandelt die Geschichte danach, was danach passiert. Weil er auch betrunken war, ne? War das der Film? Ne? Nee. Was war denn der Film, da war auch Tom Hanks auch ein Pilot, weil er betrunken war. Das war doch der Film, der ist doch alkoholkrank oder nicht. Ist er nicht alkoholkrank? Nein. War ein ganz alter Pilot. Nein. Hallo. Sorry, ey, kannst du ruhig ... Hallo, Caro. Ich weiß, wieso, wir dürfen nicht drin sein, aber jeder andere Raum ist voll. Es tut mir leid, wir hatten die Auswahl ... Hallo Julia. Ja, ja. Wir hatten die Wahl zwischen amerikanischen Choreografen und dem Maskenraum. Wir wurden da rausgeschmissen, das ist unser Raum normalerweise. Hier ist Julia Becker im Podcast-UFO, herzlich willkommen. Julia Becker, hey. Möchtest du mal sagen, was du heute machst? Das darf ich nicht sagen. Ah, das darf ich nicht sagen. Okay, und ihr macht jetzt hier weiter? Du, wir müssten jetzt hier ein bisschen Haare machen tatsächlich. Wie lange dauert das denn? Eine Stunde? What? Aber wir kommen jetzt heute halt immer wieder hier. Ja. Wie lange haben wir aufgenommen? 36 Minuten. Was? Wir machen eine Pocket-Folge. Ja, wir können leider hier nicht weitermachen. Stefan erzählt gerade von seinem fantastischen Urlaub an Malediven. Ich erhoffe, den alles erzählen, aber an Julia Beckham. Ich glaube, man merkt den Unterschied. Die waren einfach so rochen, die waren einfach riesig. Ich weiß, ich habe auch eine Wasserkamera mitgenommen, habe dann tatsächlich die Wasserkamera. Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Wo kann man denn sonst hin? Ey, die gesamte Podcast-Uvo-Hörerschaft wird euch beschimpfen. Möchtest du denn mal ... Aber möchtest du mal mal in eine Folge kommen, Julia? Ja, sehr gerne. Echt jetzt mal? Wir haben mich ein paar Mal eingeladen, du hast immer abgesagt. Ja, ich bin jetzt auch noch ein. Okay, gut. Sehr gut. Dann haben wir doch hiermit die Zusage. Fantastisch. Manche Zuhörer haben gesagt, wir haben letzte Woche keine Folge aufgenommen, also diese Woche bitte zwei aufnehmen. Nein, ihr kriegt heute eine kurze, eine extra kurze Folge deswegen, und wir machen
aber hier Zusage haben wir jetzt von Julia Becker,
dass sie im Start ist. Finde ich toll,
das heißt, alle Hass und alle Beschwerden
bitte direkt an at Hatchcrab
at Julia Becker, dass diese Folge so kurz war.
Ansonsten vielen Dank natürlich für deinen fantastischen Reiseausblick.
Wie viel, was würdest du sagen, wie viele
Ich gebe drei Sonnen von 80
Sonnen, aber dabei ist eine Sonne
die beste Möglichkeit und 80 die schlechteste.
Wie viele Muscheln? Zwei.
Zwei Muscheln, sagt Stefan Tietze, der Reiseexperte.
Vielleicht ist das eine neue Rubrik, so dass wir ab und zu mal einfach Reiseziele besprechen.
Ich finde auch, manchmal sollten wir so ein bisschen mehr Einblick in das geben, was wir sonst so machen neben dem Podcast.
Da kann man auch noch ein bisschen bewerten.
Gut, das war das Podcast-Ufo, bis nächste Woche, haut rein.
Und wir heben ab.
Das ist unangenehm, wenn wir das vor anderen Leuten machen.
Ja, mega.